a second booster now available at health
district clinics and pharmacy locations
across the valley the fda has approved a
fourth dose for the immunocompromised in
those over the age of 50. a bit
controversial because there are some
experts who doubt the overall
effectiveness we're going to break this
down for you the booster shot debate is
returning we are working to get some
answers for you of course we have dr
david weissmiller of the kirk corcoran
school of medicine at unlv here to
discuss thank you so much for your time
you're quite welcoming greatly
appreciate that all right the latest
data from nevada health response
released this week shows covert numbers
still on the decline now cases continue
to drop uh they're certainly a far cry
from the peak level you can see here on
the chart that we hit during the omicron
surge back in january same with
hospitalizations so doctor do you what
do you say to people who question
whether or not the fourth dose is
necessary so at this point i think the
fourth dose is necessary for a select
group of people
those who are severely immunocompromised
so if they have severe kidney disease or
if they've had an organ transplant or
for example they have some form of
malignancy or cancer in which they're
being treated right now but those are
the highest risk groups and if you look
back to when we gave the first
immunizations to those groups
they were the first group to get the
booster because they had not responded
to the initial vaccine series i think
the most important thing that we have
now with the ability to give a second
booster
is that if we have some type of sudden
drastic change in terms of what we're
seeing in terms of infections
we would have the authority in place to
go ahead and give that boost but for
most individuals the most important
thing
are the two initial vaccines of the mrna
vaccine and then the initial boost
because those patients or those
individuals will do the best in terms of
preventing hospitalization
and preventing death certainly thank you
for that clarification
um the omicron severity ba2 now the
dominant strain here in the states um
it's faster spreading so what did the
latest studies show about how the second
booster increases the protection as
you've been talking about well whenever
we're looking at giving a boost it's
always about increasing circulating
antibody and we know that quickly wanes
the other important side to the immune
system though is what we call cellular
immunity and that's what creates the
memory that we have so right now since
we're not seeing an enormous surge in
this area and relatively speaking
nationally not seeing a surge for the
otherwise healthy individual who's
gotten both of their primary
immunizations and a boost they should
have sufficient
immune fighting ability against the
current variant what we don't want to
see is we have a surge later in the year
and we need to use that boost to get
that circulating immunity up again so we
can immediately fight the infection
which is at hand okay well we will
continue this conversation at our 4 30.
thank you so much for your time right
now doctor to be continued christian
we're going to send it back to you but
first we do want to know what your
thoughts are on the booster if you'd
like to get involved with our twitter
poll please do right now we've got about
44 percent who say they won't be getting
theirs and about 56
saying um they won't and 44 saying yes
so i got that wrong there we go i clear
to fight it up all right christian back
to you all right